it is time now for CBS morning's deals
the boarding uh we're gonna bring you
some items that could help make your day
a little easier and better all that
exclusive low prices and they just might
become Essentials in your everyday life
to start shopping now scan the QR code
on your screen right now go ahead and do
it right there on the upper left or you
can visit CBS
morningsdeals.cbsdeals.com lifestyle
Elizabeth uh lifestyle expert Elizabeth
Warner joins us right now how you doing
um well thanks for having me all right
so we have something that could help you
work out while you're sitting down yeah
and I'm supposed to take a seat yeah
yeah I'll take a seat yeah okay all
right well you put your little feet in
there okay put your feet in here this is
actually a bicycle that you can utilize
when you're working at the office put it
under your desk sitting on your favorite
chair when you change your resistance on
it you can change the resistance so
we've got manual so you can change
results speed yep it'll tell you how
long you're doing it because there's
this great LCD screen on the front so it
keeps track of your time you can use it
for your feet but you also can put it
tabletop use it for your arms increase
that resistance you'll get some of that
you can lay on your back as well and use
the pedals that way I know I saw I
actually wanted one of those and but I
was wondering how effective it is
they're really effective
you can you can feel it they're really
convenient you really have to hold your
core too oh yeah to keep it steady so
it's they're really amazing that's a
great thing yes and what does it cost
yes so this one is um you're saving
actually over 200 and it's 189 so that's
an amazing amazing savings uh all right
so Nate's got a workout in he's got a
good little bit of a sweat he's feeling
sore he wants to relax what do we got
here to help him calming cozy wrap all
right so we're talking about just like
the words calming and cozy so first of
all it's like a little cocoon you
actually put it on just like a little
sleeping bag on the bottom there's a
foot pad and that foot pad both heat and
massage yes so with your remote you can
decide if you'd like heat if you'd like
massage it would give you a little
massage feel the heat in the massage
right now yeah all right so it gives you
that nice heater massage so that person
that you know that's always freezing or
has the achy legs or achy feet this is
the best best gift and yes after having
that hard workout I feel like you've
earned them yeah these are in these are
in the massage so I mean this is that
one this one is 53.99 so it's 40 off
today but of course after a little while
of exercising relaxing yeah you may get
hungry you're gonna have to get up and
make something yes absolutely all right
so I'm gonna squeeze on by here this is
amazing so it's called the air whirl
it does so this is what it is I know and
it does go on a stove and all that kind
of stuff yeah so you take all of your
regular pots and pans at home this
actually is going to go on top when you
turn it on it turns your stove top into
an air fryer so you've got your pot and
pan from home whatever it is this fan
what's the benefit of that if you've
already cooked it so you're cooking it
with this on top and because this
circulates the air it cooks faster okay
so it saves us all a lot of time it's
like a convection oven or an air fryer
so what normally might take 30 minutes
could take 12 to 15. even has the
thermometer built in so you can keep
track of the temperature you put your
pan on the stove it's your pan there and
then you turn on the stove that's right
you put a little aluminum over your pan
and then it comes with this tray that
you're going to put inside that helps
lift it up and have the air circulates
you turn this one on it turns into an
air fryer yeah you have to buy those
separately exactly and they're bulky so
this just fits right in a drawer with
all of your other pots and pans and it
speeds up time so I did dumplings in
mine this week but you could do anything
whatever you have I look confused it's
because I am this looks like a lot of
steps to me you got to put a pan and you
got to put this yeah most people have
for people that can cook okay
yeah yeah you're always confused in the
kitchen
but this will make it easier for you and
it'll cook it faster so I batch cook and
it's a great way to reheat food like
pizza and things like that and look
Yum's for the kids it's chicken yep you
fry it on your pan and then you put this
in you can you can do it all with this
on so you've got the pan on the stove
you put the chicken in yes Elizabeth
goes scale as I said what
for people that cook I hear this is
fabulous look at this order delivery
yeah now you're talking but this is
yes absolutely so this is 45 off so now
it's just 32.99 so that's an amazing
Elizabeth want to thank you so much of
course we partnered with all these
companies to get these deals you can buy
anything that you saw scan a QR code on
your screen right now or head over to
cbsdeals.com